das war eine gute viertelstunde wladimir
selensky zugeschaltet aus der kriegs
hauptstadt darüber sprechen wir jetzt
werden wir weiter dieses live bild aus
dem bundestag sehen hier im studio sehen
sie zwischen uns alexander ott jansky er
steht dem präsidenten der ukraine ganz
nah er berät ihn nämlich in kiew bis
jetzt für ein paar tage kurz hier in
berlin ehe er zurück kehrt noch einmal
herzlich willkommen bei uns herr ott
janszky und zugeschaltet aus kiew paul
ronzheimer er hat jansky wir gehen
einfach zur tagesordnung über das ist so
das gefühl was uns hier gerade trifft im
studio wir haben eine aufrüttelnde rede
gesehen und jetzt gehts halt um die
nächsten um innenpolitische themen um
corona unter anderem wie geht es ihnen
damit ja das ist natürlich einerseits
verständlich weil das leben in europa
weiter geht es herrscht ja bis jetzt
kein krieg hier andererseits tut uns das
natürlich leid und es gibt auch
unverständnis aus der ukraine wir weil
wir uns eben handeln wünschen wie schon
eben angesprochen es geht um mehr
waffenlieferungen für den luftschutz und
es geht natürlich um sanktionen die dann
die kriegsmaschine in russland anhalten
würden das wünschen wir uns ganz
dringend weil dort fehlt uns einfach die
zeit die zeit geht uns davon die
menschen sterben täglich und wenn das
jetzt so weiter geht dann besteht eine
ernste gefahr dass das auch weiter
eskaliert und über die grenzen der
ukraine hinaus paul ronzheimer für uns
in käfertal werden diese rede verfolgt
wer hatten hier gänsehaut seelands
gerhard an die historische verantwortung
deutschlands erinnert daran erinnert
dass in europa ein volk vernichtet wird
dass wir ganz lange die sanktionen auf
die lange bank geschoben haben er hat er
ganz konkret die finger in die wunden
gelegt und hat auch das formuliert was
er von deutschland erwartet eine rede
die wir hier wären absoluten schweigen
verfolgt haben und dann geht man einfach
im bundestag zur tagesordnung über
nächste punkt corona beer hat das auf
dich gewirkt dort in kiew
ich schäme mich nur noch für dieses
tagesordnung deutschland diese kalte
politik man muss sich das mal vorstellen
während klose lenski dort geredet hat
man hier sirenen zu hören hier in kiew
wieder luft sirenenalarm er bittet
verzweifelt um hilfe er weist auf die
dramatischen fehler hin die die politik
gemacht hat er sagt wie kann es sein
dass amerika mehr hilft als deutschland
und was ist die antwort unserer politik
wir reden über corona mir fehlen da
wirklich die worte paul noch einmal der
bundeskanzler ist ja auch direkt
angesprochen worden zum ende dieser
redet er down this wall das waren die
worte von ronald reagan mal hier in
berlin die tatsächlich zum einreißen der
mauer beigetragen haben dann und flotte
lenski spricht jetzt von dieser neuen
mauer die mauer auch in unseren köpfen
sich dort bis aufs letzte zu engagieren
in der ukraine er spricht den
bundeskanzler direkt an er dreht sich
auch um der bundeskanzler wir haben das
gerade gesehen zu der videowall auf der
man den ukrainischen präsidenten gerade
gesehen hat er dreht sich dorthin mit
seiner maske auf schaute ihm in die
augen und dann dreht sich der kanzler
eben wieder um und macht einfach weiter
ich halte das für respektlos von olaf
scholz das ist eine dermaßen kalte
reaktion in einer situation man muss
sich das einmal vorstellen wie sie
lenski entweder dort versteckt im
präsidenten gebäude wo ich auch schon
ein paar mal war wo wir ihn interviewt
haben oder an einem anderen geheimen ort
er muss jede minute damit rechnen hier
immer noch getötet zu werden wir sind
scharfschützen in der stadt die ihn
immer noch jagen die andere politiker
jagen und unser bundeskanzler und unsere
bundesminister die antworten nicht mal
darauf auf diese bitte die haben es
nicht mal nötig zu sagen was deutschland
darüber denkt was der deutsche
bundeskanzler darüber denkt dass er ja
so scharf kritisiert wird genauso wie
seine vorgänger regierung denn würde man
sie denn sie hat ja ganz klar gesagt
dadurch das ist keine scharfen
sanktionen gab ist es erst so weit
gekommen und ihr wollt immer noch nicht
in der form helfen wie wir das aus der
ukraine sehen da kann man ja geteilter
meinung sein ich sehe das ähnlich wie
blöde mütze lenski aber man sollte
zumindest eine haltung haben und man
sollte bitteschön den respekt haben
gegenüber einem präsidenten im krieg
darauf zu antworten selbst wenn das
nicht geplant war selbst wenn es eine
verdammte deutsche tagesordnung gibt
dann schmeißt man die mal weg dann
zerreißt man diese tagesordnung und dann
antwortet man verdammt noch mal auf den
ukrainischen präsidenten der hier im
krieg steht und eine bitte
dort geäußert hat was ist das für eine
politik vielleicht können wir noch mal
ganz kurz rein bevor wir auch wieder zu
ihnen kommen herrollen jansky was gerade
im bundestag läuft also da haben wir
gerade friedrich merz den
oppositionsführer gesehen haben wir ganz
kurz rein was dort gerade passiert
müssen stehen wir eigentlich heute als
bundesrepublik deutschland an der
richtigen stelle wenn es um diesen
punkten
[Musik]
sind wir waren doch in einer solchen
debatte angekommen friedrich merz der
über die rede von salans die dort
spricht jetzt im deutschen bundestag der
debatte die wir hier gehabt haben über
eine stunde schweigend auf der
regierungsbank gesessen heute nachmittag
führen wir eine diskussion über die
menschenrechtslage in der ukraine und
frau präsidentin mit verlaub sie sagen
uns heute morgen wieder beirat der
kleinen forscher besetzt werden soll
meine damen und herren wann denn wenn
nicht jetzt eine diskussion eine
zwischenbilanz eine frage an uns selbst
obwohl wir nicht
vielleicht und fremd ist und wenn es nur
darum geht uns noch einmal selbst zu
vergewissern wo wir stehen unter
bundeskanzler ich finde dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland anspruch
darauf hat von ihnen heute morgen zu
erfahren wie sie die lage sehen und
welche schlussfolgerungen daraus zu
ziehen haben wenn sie allerdings spd
grüne und fdp mit ihrer meinung hier
eine mehrheitsentscheidung durchsetzen
dann will ich ihnen von unserer seite
aus nur sagen dies stößt ausdrücklich
auf unseren widerspruch und unsere
missbilligung wir sind damit nicht
einverstanden
an den lokalen hat den deutschen
bundestag hier tritt jetzt
menschlichkeit auf tagesordnung
sozusagen also das haben viele offenbar
im plenum gerade genau so erlebt wie wir
hier im studio man muss doch darüber
diskutieren jetzt hören wir noch mal
weiter rein was passiert jetzt gibt es
eine antwort von olaf scholz ändert man
jetzt die tagesordnung schmeißt man das
werk diskutiert man über die rede von
ziele und über den ukraine krieg
die gesellschaft ausschließlich märz die
im juni hatte schon im vorfeld gesagt
sie hat heute eine debatte der ampel
regierung hat nämlich statt cdu hat das
abgelehnt und darüber hat gerade in
friedrich merz ganz klar seinen unmut
kund ja auch nochmal direkt auch an dem
olaf scholz berichtet an den
bundeskanzler
was passiert jetzt
jetzt geht es weiter
tagesordnungspunkt wenn man noch mal
rein
frau präsident sind meine
sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen
präsident selensky
hat gerade eben eine sehr eindringliche
rede gehalten
dafür
[Applaus]
oder
dafür danke ich ihm ausdrücklich
er formale worte jetzt
um dann womöglich zur tagesordnung
überzugehen die ampel koalition
sind überzeugt dass die worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten für sich stehen
sie haben es verdient für sich
wahrgenommen zu werden
[Musik]
also das sind die worte von katja mast
ersten parlamentarischen
geschäftsführerin der spd sie begründete
jetzt warum es aus ihrer sicht richtig
ist weiterzumachen
leiden seit dem 24
februar unter schrecklicher kriegsgewalt
durch putins truppen sie kämpfen sie
leiten sie haben angst
sie fliehen
familien werden auseinandergerissen und
menschen sterben tätig und fallen in
diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
mit diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
auf die ukraine hat der russische
präsident
grundlegende
internationale normen und werte mit
füßen getreten
deswegen hat der bundeskanzler
unmittelbar darum gebeten am sonntag den
februar vor dem deutschen bundestag eine
regierungserklärung
abzugeben
er hat diese zeitenwende
umfassend erläutert und antworten darauf
gegeben im anschluss hat es hier im
deutschen bundestag eines sehr lange
ausführliche aussprache gegeben das war
angemessen
also katja maaß die spd-abgeordnete die
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin der
fraktion der
regierungsfraktion die begründet jetzt
gerade warum man nicht noch mehr eingeht
auf die worte des ukrainischen
präsidenten sie sagt sie haben das hat
es doch alles schon gegeben hier im
bundestag der kanzler hat doch eine
regierungserklärung gehalten paul
ronzheimer ich weiß nicht ob du uns noch
hörst in kiew vielleicht können wir noch
mal gemeinsam werden wir auch immer
wieder in den bundestag gleich
eintauchen das nochmal kommentieren also
paul rust gerade ins bild verzeihung
wenn wir das jetzt hören der bundestag
der hat gerade damit sich selbst da
passiert gerade was friedrich merz der
das ist auch so empfunden hat und gesagt
hat jetzt kann man doch nicht einfach
hier weitermachen nach so einer
aufrüttelnden rede und jetzt befasst man
sich damit man hadert gerade macht man
weiter oder nicht wie erlebst du diese
momente in kiew
ich habs grad schon mal gesagt ich
schäme mich für mein land und meine
politiker die dort zur tagesordnung
übergehen wollen ich erhalte das
mir fehlen da wirklich die worte wie man
auf diese verzweifelten bitten des
ukrainischen präsidenten und diese klare
kritik ja auch an der deutschen
regierung am deutschen bundeskanzler an
der vorgänger-regierung damit ist nicht
nur die spd gemeint oder die grünen oder
die fdp sondern genauso die union wir
müssen doch grundsätzlich darüber
sprechen wenn ein ukrainischer präsident
im krieg sagt dass amerika offenbar der
ukraine näher steht als deutschland zwei
flugstunden von hier entfernt sitzen
roth die politiker zusammen und wollen
jetzt nicht darüber sprechen und dann
finden sie irgendwelche absurden
ausreden und sagen wir haben man hat ja
schon ende februar darüber geredet und
man wolle die worte des präsidenten für
sich stehen lassen also ich glaube der
präsident hätte sehr gerne eine antwort